You can use Analytics to get other
kinds of data, not just screen views.
I'll quickly show you
the kinds of data you can get,
and then you'll try it out for yourself.
You can add code to your app to
find out what your users are doing
by sending data to Analytics to track
events, like when a button is clicked.
Or if you're building a game,
say, you could send an event
when a user unlocks a new level.
Here's an example of the event
screen in the Analytics dashboard.
So you see the category of the event,
and you see the actions.
You can find out if your users
are doing what you hoped they'll do
by setting goals.
For example, you might set a goal for
the users to click the Buy Now button,
or click on an ad, or
reach a certain page.
So here you see that one of the goals
is for the users to rate the app.
So you can track how users browse and
buy.
If your app let's users view products and
buy them,
you can track how the customers
progress through the shopping flow.
You can see which products get purchased
in the product performance page.
And you can track the steps throughout
the purchase and checkout process.
To track the way users view and
buy things, your app needs to have
the structure and code in place.
For users to browse products,
add them to the cart, checkout.
And then to get the Analytics data,
you need to add code to send a hit to
Analytics at each stage of the process.
You can also track how long it takes for
things to happen in your app.
You need to write the code to time
the task that needs to be timed.
And then you add the code to send the
hit to Analytics to report the timing
data.
And you see the timing info in the App
Speed page in the Behavior section
in the dashboard.
And you can track when things go wrong.
You can send data to Analytics when
your app throws an exception or,
in the hopefully unlikely event,
has a crash.
So here are examples of
a couple different exceptions.
You can also track how
users download your app.
In this course we're not going to
put our app on the Play Store, so
I'll leave you to explore how to track
down those sources in your own time
with an app that you've
published to the Play Store.
So that was a roundup of the kinds of
things you can track with Analytics.
Now, let's go do some tracking.